what up guys i'm bart welcome back to
the ice coffee hour and so far this
podcast had made a hundred and three
sets hundred and three thousand
hundred and three thousand and seven
hundred dollars
nice and is that like a a rolling tally
that you guys keep about how much this
podcast has made it is we started that
our
not our first ever ever since we were
monetized yeah we were saying how much
we had made it was fun in the very
beginning because you would see such a
big difference between week three and
like week five what was week one like
zero dollars
or pre-sold ads
we we hit the ground running yeah well i
think it was like a hundred bucks or so
in our first week okay 200 bucks
something like that i don't know we got
monetized pretty quickly and then
everything after that because we had
such long episodes yeah i would uh
put ads in the video perfect i always
say ads i do the ads and i'll like load
up the ads and then i would show it to
graham and graham be like okay
everything checks out except uh it needs
uh 50 more ads
i would put ads in between jacks yeah
oh does the same to me still so this is
uh just on youtube where you guys put on
itunes too it's on everything on
everything i see so you're gonna be
everywhere perfect so is the 103 000 is
that uh just like adsense alone or just
adsense that's it awesome yeah just
adsense it's been about a year it's been
about a year and five weeks or so yeah
and what's the point of adding that up
just to like motivate the viewers that
they can get after it yeah we're
listening we're a finance channel so we
dive into the finances and uh get to the
bottom of everything so i think part of
that is just like we want to be upfront
with how much the podcast makes that's
we like to scratch the itch that the
viewers probably have they want to know
yeah yeah and if you don't have the itch
you're still going to scratch it yeah
that's one of the things that actually
drew me to your channel yeah like i'm
always just looking at random things and
then i think there's this one where it
was showing your uh
like your portfolio pretty much i forgot
how much it was but you started off with
your story of like when you're 18 or 19
got into real estate you started
stacking like real estate homes and like
and the transparency of it i think
it's super cool because
usually even if you have a close family
friend that is someone in like finance
or whatever
when you ask them like direct questions
they usually kind of give it to you in
bits and pieces or still kind of beat
around the bush but you never really get
a clear idea of what you're supposed to
do you know so i always thought that was
super cool and i liked it i like that
you
that that on this episode you make 103
700. you got it we want to make this
about you man okay so tell us a little
bit about yourself you're into
bodybuilding uh i got to get to your
level at some point
you got to tell us not only how you got
into this how you built up a youtube
channel to a pretty substantial amount
um how you've turned that into a
business of bodybuilding and then also
how jack and i could get in shape
and how the viewer how we could get six
minute apps and how you're here because
you're our neighbor yes exactly yeah
yeah okay so yeah um
it started off in 2007.
um in the my junior year of college me
and my buddy we didn't really quite know
what youtube was just yet i was about to
transfer from a jc to ucla my other
buddy was also
transferring from a community college
into a four-year and he sent me this
video on youtube and he drew like two
eyeballs on his chin and he filmed just
this much upside down yeah i remember
that yeah and he was he he was like
telling this sad story about how his a
dog died but it's it's a comedy video
yeah he sent it to me and through aim
and i thought it was like the most
aol instant messenger yeah and i thought
it was i loved that yeah i thought it
was the most hilarious thing i've ever
seen
so i recorded another video called uncle
sam gets jacked and i did it in my
bathroom and i poured contact solution
on my eyes pretending like i was crying
and i sent it back to him
and we thought like youtube was like
photo bucket where it's just a place
that stores content
and uh both of our videos started
getting like 300 views 500 views 800
views and then we're like oh [ __ ]
there's other people that are like
watching this that's who leaked the
video that's just not between you and me
you know yeah and then we'd read the
comments you guys got to make more and
it's one of those things where i think
like the stars aligned where we're in
the middle of transferring so there's
not much to do that summer so we just
decided to dedicate that summer to
making all kinds of like weird comedic
sketches
and we actually really fell in love with
this so we created a channel called just
kidding films
and that's 2007 and it's like all comedy
sketches
and so fast forward to probably like um
maybe like
2011 or 2012 after all of our shoots
like we were shooting
at least what we were trying to shoot
was like key and peel a chapel show type
stuff so there's high production there's
always locations and casts and stuff and
after we shoot we always have like these
parking lot
discussions with our friends and we're
just cracking up for like four hours and
we're like we need to shoot this
so we created a roundtable talk show
called just kitty news both of those
channels ended up getting to uh like a
million each
and from that point on
um people have always seen me like i
guess look a little bit more built
so they're like oh like barb like put
out your fitness programs or like how do
you train
and i'm like you know i'm not a personal
trainer i just like lifting for myself
um but i was like you know what i can
show you i guess my journey so i started
a fitness channel just to kind of have
people come along
and that kind of started to take off a
little bit and i was like you know what
i i feel like i'm pretty strong in the
gym
like how strong am i compared to
like the rest of the state or whatever
so i signed up for this thing called
powerlifting i didn't really know what
it was i just wrote like google strength
competition or whatever powerlifting
came up and you compete in the squat the
bench the deadlift and so i signed up
for my very first powerlifting meet and
i think that kind of gave it like um
i guess like a little viral catalyst
because at that time it's
anything that was journey based on
youtube was very intriguing to people
so i signed up i competed i did pretty
good and i was looking for a
powerlifting gym and i couldn't find one
in la
and i pitched to my friends like we had
our jk office already i'm like what if i
just get like a container fill it up
with equipment and we just saw a train
in there and overnight like 20 of my
buddies like well i'll chip in
and i'm like oh wait if i can get 20
people overnight
maybe we can get like members you know
like i don't know how many members i can
get to cover the rent so me and my wife
we literally went to barnes and noble
and we found like a how to write a
business plan book
and the one that we chose was one where
like after every chapter there's a
worksheet
so if you fill out the worksheet at the
end of every chapter you technically
have a business plan so we're like let's
just do that and we'll do like an hour a
day because we're like full time doing
jk we're like we'll do that now our day
none of us know how to open a brick and
mortar let's see what happens and we
finished the whole book
and we we went to the city got like you
know permitting like the the right
zoning and all of that and then we
started a crowdfund on our website and
in two weeks we got 100 members and that
was enough for
us to break even
so i'm like okay if we can break even
and this is a side project anyways
then i get like a free gym to train in
so we open
and that kind of took off became its own
gym we moved to downtown l.a where we
have over 400 members now um it's like a
6 000 square foot warehouse and then we
built
like a fitness and peril and supplements
and all that stuff like on top of that
so now there's like these two like main
babies and that's kind of like the two
of the most the two of the things i'm
most involved in
the most i had no idea about any of this
all right that's no that's incredible
you've been successful in everything
that you've put your mind to i got super
lucky because that's what we always talk
about because i have other buddies that
are in like
like the apparel industry and they're
like dude i had five failed t-shirt
businesses before this one took off and
i'm like i don't know maybe you just got
the good people around me or something
yeah what got you into fitness to begin
with um where did that start so that's
actually funny because uh i got into
fitness back in
i would say
like 1999 or 2000 so i'm 37 okay
and back in like the late 90s early
2000s like the stuff that you hear on
the radio was like tupac big it was like
super like gangster everything was
gangster so usually most people get into
fitness through
like health and wellness i got into it
because all of my homies older brothers
just got out of jail and that's the
thing that we did we just lifted in the
garage and smoked cigarettes which is
kind of like opposite to fitness
so i grew up in l.a but it's like
gabriel valley okay and at that time it
was at that time it was like the asian
gang capital of the world
um it's a little bit different now it's
quite nice yes yeah yeah yeah but before
it was like asian gain capital the world
so i got into lifting through the guys
that were trained in jail
yeah and what happened with your
original youtube channel like when did
you do you continue to make content for
it did you stop making content for it
was it profitable at the time
yeah so at one given time
i think we were super maxed out we had
jk films which was sketch comedy we had
this one called ask the feels where we
actually have callers call in and then
that was um
a kind of like a relationship and also
sex like fun talk type of channel we had
jk party which is a game show channel
then we have barbell brigade which is
like the fitness channel and had a
personal vlog so at one given point in
time
i had five of those channels going and
we were just so so burnt out from that
that i think once we hit our like max
bandwidth we started to dial back down
so one of the first things that went um
was ask the feels because that was just
more like for shits and giggles and fun
but the second one that went was just
kidding films and that one kind of hurt
a little bit because that was kind of
like the start of it all but with like
the youtube algorithm changing
it just didn't make sense to put almost
like two or three weeks of
pre-production production
post-production into a video
and then post it and we have to do this
like one week cycles so it's almost like
trying to produce like chappelle show
level
skits uh when you don't have that kind
of team yeah you know like those guys
they they could be if dave chappelle's
not in all the videos they could be
shooting all five videos at the same
time you know different locations
whatever for us it's like all hands on
deck for every single video and we were
just so burnt out from that so
unfortunately that was the one that um
the second one i had to shut down
and
it still gets good views but that's not
something we're active on yo yo yo but
first we gotta thank our sponsor extra
alex take off the hat man that's my
thing
jack do you know the one thing i
absolutely hate when people say that you
need to post longers to family videos
well i mean yes but i also hate how
people say that you have to have a
credit card to build credit but you do
don't you wow jack you've obviously
never heard of extra
you're extra alex
anyway jack extra is actually a debit
card that lets you build credit and earn
reward points just like a credit card
wow dave ramsey is probably over the
moon right now he probably is especially
when he finds out how simple it is to
use you just connect extra to your
existing bank account swipe the card to
buy something and then they spot you for
the purchase and pay themselves back the
next business day and boom at the end of
the month your payments are added up and
reported directly to the credit bureaus
and they do all of that without a single
credit check can you believe that i do
believe that because they're extra so
sign up for extra with our link extra
dot app slash ich and start building
credit now with a debit card yes i said
it a debit card and if anyone out there
knows dave go ahead and send him our
link thank you so much extra for
sponsoring this episode and back to the
podcast
got it i want to know more about the
fitness though jack switch you switch
topics too quickly
how do you go from just working out with
your buddies yeah to then getting like
yolked that doesn't happen like how do
you how much how much time did you put
into this what was your routine like
what were you eating like walk us
through your day to like to go from just
working out with your buddies who got
out of jail to then
getting big okay so it was kind of like
like
these days you can go online and
research a lot of stuff and you get
pretty decently accurate information
really quickly and you can kind of
jumpstart your fitness career for me
it was kind of like a lot of trial and
error because it's either those guys
that i learn from who probably don't
know things
don't have to do things the right way or
it's the magazines that i would read at
7-eleven you know and it would be like
this is my five day split or six day
split
so the first thing that i did wrong um
was i only focused on like the show
muscles which is like just chest and
arms
and you know that's ignoring an entire
part of your body and if you want to
gain weight and build muscle
like legs is huge
so that's one thing i didn't do and then
the next thing is one of the biggest
pieces of advice that someone told me
was i used to work out at this place
called bally's and one of those like
really really big bodybuilder guys he
was like if you're not stuffed you're
wrong if you're trying to gain weight
meaning what he told me and this is
probably the unhealthy way to do it but
what he told me is you should oh you
should be so stuffed
that you
should feel like you're about to throw
up
at any time
and if the minute that that feeling goes
down it goes put another cheeseburger in
your mouth no so i followed that and i'm
like you know what if this is the right
way to do it and it's not the right
but i'm like if this is the right way to
do it then uh
i just started i started eating like two
four by fours
um every single day just for one meal
and i would have like two breakfast
burritos at night and i would pound
maybe two uh one or two protein shakes
throughout the day wow
and i got from
one
like 150 to 190 in about six months
did you get fat yes i mean you put on
calories so you you just kind of like
blow up but then like the abundance of
calories helps you put on of course both
fat and muscle but the important thing
is that surplus of calories kind of puts
you in like this anabolic state where
you get very strong and the strength
helps you build the muscle over time
were you skinny growing up or yeah you
were yeah yeah yeah so in high school um
when i got my freshman year i was like
90 pounds and i didn't break a hundred
until like a sophomore no way yeah yeah
and then i in my junior year i wrestled
and i wrestled like 120s 130s yeah so i
graduated high school finally because i
started lifting my junior year and i got
from 130 to around like 150 160ish
and then afterwards is when i really
started like pounding the food yeah so
when you were packing on a lot of muscle
and fat from eating a lot yeah where did
where did that evolve from there
yeah what happened after that so then
you did you got way bigger yeah did you
then go on to go on a cut to to lose the
fat or how how did this evolve after
that yeah so i got pretty big and i kept
that going for a while probably up to
like past 200 because like that was just
the number that i wanted to break and
you know a lot of people want to get to
like 200 pounds
once i got there and i started to
realize that okay i don't think it's
healthy to wear size 38 jeans when i was
like a 30 or 32 before
i started to dial it back down
fortunately as well i was in the
military at the time
so there's you have to have like kind of
like a bmi check where they like measure
your chest to waist ratio and if you're
not what they call regs like under
regulations
you won't be able to get promoted
because the last thing you want is like
like a fat soldier you know
so uh
when i got when i got measured and my my
whole bmi was too high and i was trying
to chase the next rank then i started
jogging way more i cleaned up my diet
and so now the thing that i keep is i
make sure i get a gram of protein per
body weight per pound of body weight so
i'm like 190 right now so i make sure i
get 190 grams of protein a day
um and then i fill the rest of my meals
up with
as much veggies as i can and then
whatever um
and whatever amount of carbs i need to
keep me satiated so that's kind of how
how i ball park it but if you really
want to be like particularly you got to
track your macros which is like your
macro nutrients yeah that kind of stuff
what drives you to be so focused on
on like bodybuilding gaining weight
working out and all that stuff and
always getting bigger because for me
it's like i go to the gym yeah and i do
it mostly just to look toned like i
don't have any desire to get huge or
anything i don't know about graham
because i think
his arms look great
thanks it's a facade it's a facade i
don't know i take off my shirt and i was
like no my my tummy is too big i don't
like it
like what what what is in you that makes
you want to get huge is it just like the
aesthetic or is it like like because you
grew up skinny or do you think it's
because it's healthy like i think in the
beginning it starts off like an
aesthetic
and um
also
growing up in that
era like you just got into a lot of
fights so if you're a little bit bigger
um you just do better in fights and i
mean now you can take an actual martial
art and actually learn how to fight
instead of just look intimidating so
that's kind of how it started off in
high school
um but as i got older and i found
more
i guess like physical hobbies like
whether it's like mma
or like lifting competitions
that's kind of what fuels me
to want to like train and and lift so
now i don't lift to try to be the
biggest myself possible
now it's just for like what do i want to
do and i kind of reverse engineer my
program to achieve that so like i grew
up with asthma and i've never been good
at cardio so in 20 19 20 20. i don't
know the pandemic years getting kind of
mixed up but yeah 2020 yeah i have
asthma too okay yeah so in 2020 i was
like
um
2019 i signed up for a marathon just
because i'm like i suck i always say
like i have asthma and cardio sucks and
all that so i'm like i want to sign up
for one and then hire a running coach to
coach me for like three months
and so
when i signed up for that
like my lift thing got like reduced like
crazy you know because you're like
running three times a week
sometimes you're like the lengths are
like 12 13 miles then you have like a
day of a seven mile like pacer and you
have like a light what they call like it
could be a seven or nine miler like
you're just jogging for rhythm
and so for me it's finding physical
endeavors
that i like and then now using the
training to kind of like
um help me achieve it so i think it's
the challenge for you right yeah i think
so
and i think you apply that to everything
whether it be
fitness or business right
i think so yeah i guess i'm like
figuring out myself here you know the
funny thing is that i've seen that
people who are really into fitness tend
to be
really good at other things too because
they're disciplined and they get they
could push through that pain to achieve
a greater result
yeah that's one thing i noticed that
people that are uh
who have been able to transform their
bodies
um they've actually been able to
transform other parts of their life
because in fitness like once you start
coaching and you kind of figure out
almost a formula to
achieving what you want you can pretty
much adjust like three variables
uh one is frequency like how often you
do something intensity like how hard
you're doing it while you're doing it
and volume like how much of it you're
doing and just through these three
manipulations you can
get bigger get smaller you can get
faster
and i think with the other parts of
business or even your relationship you
can do the same thing like my my
relationship with my mom isn't that good
well is it because i'm not seeing her
enough or because you're not working out
enough exactly
yeah like or if you see your mom and
um half of the time you're on your phone
so you're not that intense working on
the relationship you know so i feel like
um
applying like having those principles
ingrained in you on a daily where you're
working out has helped a lot of fitness
people figure out other parts of their
lives too got it did you go to college
yes and what do you study in college
something completely different i was a
psycho bio major um it's kind of like on
the pre-med track but then when i
started doing the comedy videos with my
partner joe
um
comedy was just way more fun than
science yeah
when did you go into uh active duty
so i actually wasn't active duty i was
in the reserves in the reserve yeah so
after high school you still got to go to
boot camp um you still got to go to like
marine corps uh training combat training
and then you have to go to mos school so
so all of that is like almost a year of
kind of active but you're not really
like in the fleet as they call it but as
soon as you're done with that then you
go to your reserve unit and so i was
able to balance um the second part of my
college with my military career so
you're doing both of those concurrently
yes
gosh and then you graduated from that is
that when you decided to go full time to
youtube yeah like that my senior year
the craziest senioritis i was like man
this stuff's so boring
and like
all i could think about was
shooting more youtube videos like i was
tutoring students at the time as a
part-time job
and i would literally be like all right
um here do questions like one through 50
and i know that was going to occupy them
for a good 30 minutes and i would just
write like content ideas like on the
site like every single day
yeah my partner too like we would meet
um at 8 p.m
uh till 11 at night monday through
friday
because she was working a full-time job
and i was working and then on the
weekends we were dedicated to shoot like
a 12-hour day saturday and sunday we
kept it like a year what were the
finances like at the beginning of that
were you making money from youtube back
then now
all right so our first assets check yeah
uh was a thousand bucks
and we were so
happy because we're just two broke
college students and we didn't even know
that you can get paid you know and then
we're like wait a second this was for
like
six months worth of videos
we're like damn i don't think that's
really that good to be honest i don't
know if this is sustainable
um
but we promised ourselves if we can
by the time uh like college finished if
we can get to a point
where if just both me and him can be
like full-time meaning like he makes a
thousand books i make a thousand bucks
my mom owned a rental property that she
said she would just let me stay at at
the time then my keep my expenses low if
we can at least just get to that point
then we're like who knows what the
channel can can achieve once we go full
time into it so that was kind of like
the goal
let's get it to making like two or three
thousand bucks a month and then we're
gonna quit our jobs and go full time
what year was that
that was probably
maybe 2010 2011. wow around there what
channels did you look look up to back
then
back then um of course ryan hugo he was
like number one
really wait john uh really yeah william
ray johnson cuz and ray william johnson
yeah um because he was just
crushing it not only on his channel with
the amount of quantity that was coming
out but he started doing a like spanish
version
of equals three and i'm just like man
these guys are thinking like next level
you know it's like this is my audience
how do i expand expand expand expand and
you just see like this very
um like how do i increase my market and
territory like it almost feels like um
like very business very strategic
um
and also uh oh man i don't even know if
he's around anymore
but there's this guy named um
i think his name was julian something
julian smith 87 yes oh my god he did
that i love him
yeah he did akbar he did waffles he did
a jellyfish he did all the songs they
also did a lot of
milkmail
that was a long time like he didn't make
very many videos but each one he made
was like boom like 10 million like 2
million like he was crushing it
and that was like the first time i saw
some like really good artistry being put
on like like short films got it
so like those were the guys that i
looked up to and of course like just all
the ogs you know yeah so when did you go
full time how fast were you able to go
from a thousand dollars in an adsense
check to like three grand a month
so we went once we got to 2000 um
we all quit our jobs and i think from 2
000 to 6 000 we were able to get within
like six months so with that we're able
to hire on like a actual like
a full-time director editor videographer
and uh that was like the first i think
the minute you can kind of scale a
little bit and delegate some of the
duties like that was that was everything
like yeah yeah that afforded us to be
able to um
get a bigger team with bigger team we
get more content and now we're shooting
behind the scenes for the skits so now
we're like doubling up on the content we
open another channel
and then i think the minute we're able
to get to like 10 or 11 grand a month
that helped us be able to get our first
studio
so now we don't have to shoot stuff from
the home and we're hiring people it just
i don't know it felt like more legit
yeah and how many subscribers did you
have when you were making like six
thousand dollars a month
hmm
don't remember maybe like
two or three hundred thousand
subscribers maybe it's pretty good what
were you do you mind sharing what you
were making at the peak
oh man that channel yeah so at the peak
from just adsense or from maybe we
separate the two you just won an adsense
and then just like a total
so when we had
all of the channels up and running i
think our best
our best
year we're probably doing about 200
grand a month i think
with all the channels added together and
that's with adsense was that is that
including sponsorships and everything
that was just the adsense um there was
this one year uh where the
this company
doesn't exist anymore but they were
really trying to like compete and they
gave us like a really big seven figure
uh brand deal that was super cool but
and they had all the right people
involved like
uh the head of programming from amazon
prime was in it i think um a couple guys
from hulu were in it um and they were
trying to do like capitalize on first
window
where
if you are an uber fan you would watch
stuff here first before they put it on
their youtube channel and they got a
bunch of big youtubers together so that
helped out
um a lot that was like our first like
big big brand deal that we're like oh
this is like crazy yeah wow so it's a
multi-million dollar business what's the
overhead look like on something like
that um at the time people yeah how many
people are working on that so when we
were growing like the jk side of things
um we were just growing and scaling and
growing and scaling and we wanted to be
like our own tv network
so we ended up getting this huge space
in downtown l.a and that was 17 grand a
month just for like the office
and then we spent another 300 like
building our own sound stage and that
was crazy it was like like a truss
system we had like 40 kinos there's like
mixers and like
like all the cast members are loved
they're pretty much trying to shoot our
own nickelodeon yeah
um
so i think all of that kind of like
added to the burnout because when you
think about content
i've now i've learned like the easiest
way you want to figure out what's the
easiest um
the easiest way to achieve developing
your idea but we had so much like
operation and how-to to get there
that anytime we needed we had one idea
it's like okay cool everyone sits down
once we sit down and we pre-produce and
then you know so everything there was
like so many additional steps
and it kind of took the fun out of
like it you know like took the fun out
of it it's almost like if you wanted to
cook something before you want to cook
it you have to go sharpen your knives
for an hour it was kind of like that got
it so yeah that that kind of like all
led to so we were making big money but
also lots of operation like maybe 30 40
people on staff wow and it became this
huge operation
and
so as me and my partner our first time
doing business at this level we're like
damn this is crazy and we really had to
do a sit-down like is this what we
wanted to do
so now we scale down way more we instead
of having both of our offices we just
have the one office
and that place is only two thousand
dollars a month
and
it feels like our channel or just
kidding news channel has so much of its
heart and charm back to it now because
we're not so much focused on like the
numbers and the operations and the
things it's more about it's more content
driven yeah so kind of having gone full
circle like that feels the best now i
want to know because i know graham would
not do this but you scaled back the
business and i wouldn't do this i
wouldn't even scale listen like the 40
people to me sounds intimidating it was
nice just the idea of even like i was i
was thinking about uh getting on an
editor to help me on my man and just
thinking about another person
can't do it right but i want to keep now
i i like just jack and alex but here's
the thing it's like if you scaled and
you knew for a fact you could hire on 10
more people but make 20 times more money
like that's the stress for me it's the
mental stress
so that was for you it was the stress
and the weight of it all is what led you
to decide to scale down a little bit
yeah it's like um
yeah it's kind of like you you love dogs
right and you have one or two
and then you're like well let's add to
my love of dogs i'm gonna get 20.
and then when because you're thinking of
of like the
the reels or like the tick tock of 20
dogs running around in your backyard and
they're all cuddling on you and then the
day they all like take a fat [ __ ] you're
like [ __ ] that's 20 pieces of dookie i
gotta walk them and i gotta order like
20 bags of dogs are they gonna hire
somebody to uh to clean that up yeah so
it was like every time we had a shoot
day
our lunches would be the lunch budget
for each shoot day was 300 to 500 bucks
like each time you know it's just
everything but everything just scales
how much money were those videos making
like how much would it cost to make a
video versus how much would you expect
to make from the channel
i wish i got that granular with it um we
actually had hired a manager to run like
the numbers and finances part of it so
we i gave him bro broad like kind of
like limits and categories and as long
as they stayed there and we kept our so
our goal was always to keep cost of
operation between 40 and 60
so if after
all of the pre-production
um staff and labor equipment all that
stuff if that can be 60
or under
we're good um and that's all that's all
i wanted to worry about yeah because i
wanted to stay focused on the creative
side of things that seems expensive
though i can't imagine sixty percent
overhead for a youtube channel i mean it
makes sense yeah i can only imagine what
jubilees is like
jubilee
no their overhead isn't that much they
don't they don't pay the people that go
on
no they don't pay the people to go on
they pay like a hundred dollars
they got an incredible warehouse they
have a team of probably 15 to 25 people
they have a great office space i think
it's like around uh it's sautel i don't
know but uh they have a good team that
they built up but i imagine those videos
can not be cheap that's true imagine
imagine casting but then they do a new
episode like three times a week imagine
casting yeah 20 people per episode
assuming that like half of them flake
last minute
it's got to be i
i don't know yeah they probably have
like a team of producers if they oh yeah
come out with that much content every
single week so why didn't you when you
realize that like hey this is we're not
as happy doing this why didn't you
immediately start just scaling down and
getting right back to doing the same
content it seemed like it was a slow
process i think the tough part is you
also fall in love with your staff
like we were trying to build like this
family environment right
so
when we have like big dreams we're like
we're growing our team
and then uh
now everyone has like a full-time job
and then now people start to have
families or they're like they have
girlfriends or they want to move out of
their house or they're going to go buy a
house or whatever
so like all of those things like as
the boss or like as a business owner
those are things that you take into
consideration
so like it was hard for us to kind of
like if we had like a legit cfo come in
he'd probably go cut this cut this cut
this it's like business is number one
priority you know but we were so close
with our staff
that some of the decisions that we
probably should have made way sooner
we're like oh but he just got that new
place with his girlfriend like let's not
reduce hours like what else can we do so
i think for for me and my partner we
were always trying to
figure out a way to put staff first if
not find other places or other streams
of income to make it work
so because of that it just took way
longer to
make like the hard business decisions
how were you living like back then
because it's a substantial amount of
money coming in yeah uh consistently
every single month were you taking that
and investing it were you spending it
were you buying cool cars are you going
to bottle service so the first thing
that uh
that so we were renting
and
i wished your videos came on before i
think i would have learned way more
about investing in real estate back then
um but the first thing that i got was a
porsche 911 like that was always like
how old were you this i was maybe like
20
actually i don't know
no not 20. it can't be 20
31 around there okay yeah yeah yeah all
right that's that's listen i feel like
it's a reasonable age to get and that's
a great car by the way they don't
appreciate that uh yeah i mean but it's
like you also still feel young like when
i walked into the dealership like
everyone else coming in no one looked
like me yeah but you also look you look
young yeah you could surprise me
yeah you could pass for 25. easily true
yeah like yeah but even me going in
there it was kind of intimidating yeah
oh [ __ ] this is crazy like everyone's
like older everyone looks like i don't
know they've been
they've been owning the golf courses
yeah
so yeah
that was the first thing i got and most
of it i did actually save
although uh it when you have more money
it was easier to just say yes to
most experiences and life choices so for
example i knew me and my girlfriend at
the time we were gonna get married
um so we're like you know we've been
pretty much born and raised in l.a
and we've never lived in the city city
so we're like we should just test that
out to see if we would like it
so we ended up and this is like during
like the the peak of i would say when
casey neistat came on and all his vlogs
was like of new york and drone footage
yeah we're like we should try living
that life in la so we found this place
it was super sick um in downtown town
and it was like six grand a month
and for us it was easy to just go oh
yeah let's do it you know but then once
i was living there then i started
calculating i'm like okay six grand i
live here for a year that's like 70 g's
and i'm like if i live for like two
years that's like 140 150 i'm like this
is easily a down payment or a house
and we also just didn't like city living
at all like the noise never ends unlike
vegas where it's like quiet it's quiet i
love it out here and it's like 3 a.m
there's like
cars drag racing
sirens people screaming like people
coming out of games or clubs or whatever
yeah the helicopters
yes helicopters circling with the
searchlight and yeah and we were living
on the 25th floor with one of those like
those corner views and i can see that
which building is this it's called uh
717 and it's at olympic and figaro yeah
yeah we had a concierge service like it
was you felt like a boss because you
would get a phone call hey have an
amazon package let me send it up i'm
like sure and this guy would come up in
like a suit and like here you go sir you
know and i'm like damn my bruce wayne
like what the hell is this
you know that's what it felt like but we
just you got to start doing that
so i just felt like i'll get you a suit
yeah so we just felt like yeah the city
wasn't for us so we moved out but i
think being able to make more money was
it gives you options to say yes to cool
experiences like that you know got it
where would you say you wasted your
money did you ever do anything crazy
any any
balling out besides uh besides a porsche
that other than that not really but i
would say the first
thing that i think me and my partner
kind of regret but not really regret is
uh spending so much on getting
that office
so the office that we got in downtown we
spent like three to four hundred just
building out the the set
which you can't really get that money
back because the set is custom
you know it's like building like a
ellen degeneres set and so if you're
gonna leave you can't be like hey anyone
buy any ellen degeneres parts you know
it's like that's no it's so unique to
that show no one wants it
so you don't really get any money back
from that um and then also having spent
pretty much 17 grand just on the lease
alone and we were there for
what it was a five year or seven year
lease but yeah if you do the math
it's a lot you know
so if all of that money could have
went towards
we probably could have bought our own
commercial but just way smaller you know
why didn't you do that it's 17 grand a
month why did you need to be there and
not just
20 miles outside of la
i don't think we were looking at it from
a
like smart financial point of view i
think it had a little bit to do with
like keeping up with the joneses and
also like doing what you think
a startup media company was supposed to
do yep you know like an arts district
you see like all these up and coming so
you kind of get caught up in that
and you're like oh well if that company
has like a 1 000
uh square foot spot and they're paying
like four dollars a square foot like if
they're doing it shouldn't we be doing
it and then you got like
people with like cool glasses and you're
like oh we're artsy you know you just
kind of like get caught up in the hole
like sure and not viewing it from a
financially sound point of view um i
think getting caught up in that is
what is probably one of the regrets but
then also
we're also happy that we went through
all of it because then
now we know what not to do you know got
it what happened to everything in the
warehouse
so we ended up selling what we could
and there's actually a ton of lights and
equipment still just in public storage
really yeah like we have like there's
these things called like kino flows
they're like um these four foot
light bulbs
and we need those grandpa okay can we
actually
should we go shop it would be fun to go
to the way if you're gonna sell anything
yes can you give us first dibs yeah so
we have like these four foot like kinos
and we have
maybe like 40 of them
and each one of them got to be like i
don't know a ground or two or something
and we just have that stacked up we have
like all kinds of stuff still in
um like the warehouse pretty much what
are you gonna do with it how much does
that cost the warehouse
how much is that a month maybe like 500
or something it's negligible in the
grand scheme of things
but it is just like
like a like a bunch of equipment that's
just sitting there
and now you no longer
post on the just kidding because or do
you do like the the podcasty type thing
so now so i'm just kidding films we
don't but our channel just kidding news
is like our main thing so in terms of
like the jks because i had like i guess
from my perspective i have like three
three main initiatives i have my jk
stuff i have like my fitness stuff which
is completely separate from the jk stuff
and then i have like my family vlog
channel
so with the jk side of things it's just
narrowed down just to just kidding news
yeah got it who runs that right now
still the same team i still have our
manager that runs that channel
um and we have maybe like
now we might have
maybe 10 editors now because that
channel posts 10 editors yeah because
that channel posts i want to see this
i'm gonna look this up cause yeah that
channel posts anywhere from three to
five videos a day no way so we have a
lot of content that goes up on that
channel just kidding news that's
incredible i wish i could i can't i
can't bulk film videos the most i could
do is like one afternoon second channel
reaction videos and i could maybe get
three of them done it's easier when you
have more cast mates sure so like
me and like the other five we're so
close now it's literally like let's all
just shoot the [ __ ]
for the whole day and it's so easy i
feel like it would be easier if we were
to mass produce something like this a
podcast then it would be for you to do
like a second channel or main channel
because you re-say the same phrases like
five to ten times just to get the
perfect take yeah and that's that's
tough to do if you're gonna yes
producing bulk content yeah if you're
teaching it's much harder because i've
done like um like instructionals on how
to lift and stuff like that and creating
like a how to lift or instructional
video or anything with a lot of
information because you want to get it
right is so much harder than just follow
me while i work out you know because
follow me while i work out i get to like
[ __ ] around do whatever right and that's
so much easier i don't have to if i say
something wrong it kind of adds to the
charm of it versus me trying to teach
someone like how to get
like bulging triceps or something i got
to make sure i i hit the right muscle i
pronounce the muscles correctly
it's much harder so the just kidding
films i see you haven't posted on there
in four years
maybe even lots of yeah maybe almost
five years yeah yeah yeah yeah how much
does that make now five years later
i'm curious
i don't know yeah but i wouldn't be
surprised if it still made like 500
bucks to like a grand a month wow yeah i
wouldn't be surprised i wouldn't be
surprised yeah that's not bad and so now
how is your business broken down and but
oh you know what actually here's here's
another question you left california
recently yes why
so uh
i guess like many of the same reasons
that you posted in your video i think
for sure the tax benefits
you just get so much more for your money
here the cost of living is cheaper
um but i think for me
the main reason is actually like family
oriented
so
me and my wife and our extended family
were pretty much born and raised in la
and when when you have been in la for
such a long time the families just kind
of spread apart
you know because like like real estate
isn't cheap
and so you kind of go where you can
where you can afford and all that stuff
and so like our families are all like
it could be an hour two hours away from
each other
and me and my wife's dream because we
are like probably the biggest bread
winners of like our immediate family
circle it's been our dream to have
everyone be in the same city
so coming to a place where the average
house is like 300 grand or 350 grand
versus a place where the average house
is 700 grand it's just so much easier
for that dream to come to life so that's
really like our main reason like if we
come here
if we make sure we like it after the
first year then we can actually
like strategize how do we get
our whole family like within 5-10
minutes of each other if we could buy
them homes or whatever so that's like
the main driving force is trying to
bring our families like close together
how do you yeah how do you like it here
so far
so far i love it but i also kind of like
take that with a grain of salt with
myself because i just know there's
honeymoon face you know like with
anything like my
the first year of driving the porsche is
different than the third year you know
the first year it's like that's
everything like oh what the hell is that
yeah and then the third year you're like
oh that was just kind of like a basic
911.
and you see like a couple like gt2 gt3
drive by a turbo and you're like hmm i
don't know this
you know you don't get the same
right so you so it's just so
knowing that um i know that i'm in love
with vegas because it's the exact
opposite of where i came from where it's
quiet um taxes are cheaper on all levels
property tax sales tax income tax
i like that it's not congested at all
like i don't even
i mean i take mainly the 215 which is
like the local freeway so i never even
see the the the congestion that comes in
for the weekend for the casinos
um so like all of that i love
but i want to make sure that i don't get
too ahead of myself so i'm still just
kind of waiting it out so i even yeah i
told my dad because he was really
excited about coming out here too
and i was like you know what um let me
stay here for a year
and
oh and i love the school that i put my
kid in like he's loving that school and
that's like that type of school i don't
even know if i could afford if it was a
private school yeah yeah so that kind of
like the type of school that he has
right now there's only eight to ten kids
per class with two teachers wow so i was
looking for a school that i felt like i
could have thrived in where you get a
lot of attention and they have like four
recesses a day
is this the one that's kind of like down
the street-ish uh so there's a high
school down the street yeah and that's
like then i think snoop dogg kids goes
to that school like he actually that's a
gnarly they have like one of the best
football teams in the nation best
football best baseball like best
everything i think yeah because i think
when you have like
a bunch of
like a high concentration of
billionaires living in a city yeah i
think they demand the best out of like
like just the summerlin area yeah
there's just so many billionaires
because the casino owners or whatever
like they're going to demand the best
out of whatever is happening wow but
yeah he's not going to that school yet
but there's another there's a lot of
really high-end elementary schools it's
funny to even say that but yes
yeah but he has an elementary school
over here where they like they pick
fruits from their 40-acre farm
yeah they pick fruits and then that's
the same fruit that they eat uh during
snack time so they kind of have like
this oh i'm connected to my food type of
like yeah because we're so disconnected
from the supermarket right like you see
like i love chicken but then you see
someone killing a chicken you're like
hey don't do that yeah where's your
chicken gonna come from so i like that
it's it's just like this another type of
education and like um like child
development that i don't think i could
afford if it was in california but do
they do they also have like the common
core yeah yeah oh okay yeah it's like
four recesses they pick apples
like that sounds really nice yeah i know
yeah los angeles those elementary
schools would probably start at 25 to 20
000. they started that per year
and they could go as high as about 50
000 a year for anything k through i
don't know eighth grade yeah
and not only that but uh either you have
to know somebody within the school to
get in yeah or you're on a waiting list
or it's a random lottery selection
or you have to test and do it it's not
what uh what you have to do in some of
these elementary schools just how
competitive it is i know with harvard
westlake it's so competitive that
there's a waitlist for years
yeah like basically as soon as your
child is born you got to go down there
and sign them up
get get them testing well and then they
could maybe get in yeah some of them are
50 grand a year yeah i've seen some
applications where it looks like a
college application and i'm like dude my
kid's four he needs to go to preschool
but the stuff that he's like what's the
extracurriculars that he's doing it for
yeah it's crazy yeah he's not he's not
uh donating enough to charity at this at
this age where's his volunteer work
where is he volunteering where is he
working what's his resume yeah yeah so
yeah how many other foreign languages
you know
yeah so like uh
finding this school i think really helps
ground us because i'm like okay this
school is awesome and every day i ask
him he loves going to school so far
it doesn't feel like a chore which is
something easy for
and he oh i don't know if that'll last i
don't know we'll see give it to little
eight and it's gonna be i don't want to
go to school yeah yeah no stupid yeah
yeah we'll we'll see we'll see how that
how long that lasts but so far he likes
it and i just like what the school is
about
so yeah there's a lot of things keeping
me here and making me really like vegas
so i'll see if we if we do another
podcast in a year i might have a
different story but uh so far i love it
what don't you like
the heat but it's still temporary yeah i
know like literally this week it dropped
like 10 20 degrees yeah so like this
morning i woke up to go work out and i'm
like
wait this feels like california yeah
it's
it's cold yeah i'm weird i'm like this
is i did not like that i opened up the
uh the it was black hole it was a little
bit kind of you know what it was morning
it was sleeping yeah i was like 65
degrees so it's kind of like oh do i
need a light jacket yeah yeah yeah yeah
65 yeah that's perfect it is perfect but
i was like damn this is it was i almost
it's weird because i got so used to
opening up and you get to push the wave
of heat like 110 115 yeah i was used to
that so now it's weird opening it up and
it feels cold now in comparison huh i
almost don't like it i prefer the heat
that is true it's like when i initially
came here and i hit my i saw my first
like 115 degree day i was like this i am
not going to live here and then all of a
sudden like after like the 20th 115
degree day as much as that sounds like
torture like i actually kind of got used
to it and 115 degrees now is kind of
like 90. yeah you know
it's like you can go out you can do the
stuff you want to do and that's that so
have you been back to l.a
uh yeah i've been back yeah it feels
nice the irs is watching jack
i like it
i remember
i was here for like i was here for like
a month or maybe like a month and a half
before i went to la
and i didn't realize how humid la was
cause i was born and raised in l.a and
i'm like oh my god la feels kind of like
hawaii that's crazy
yeah i just felt like yeah and the smog
that i saw too yeah you know what's
something i've never had an issue with
before um but i went back to la for a
weekend i don't know this is maybe this
last week
and uh the last two times i've been to
la my asthma got so bad really really
really really bad i don't know what it
is and at first i thought maybe just the
house is dusty yeah something okay i'll
clean the house a little bit but it's
even when i would leave the house when i
would go other places it was just as bad
i think something with a pollen or
something and when you come here does it
clear up clears up immediately it's so
strange
yeah i've never had that happen so i'm
wondering if almost my body is adjusted
to whatever's here and then you go back
to la and just everything
you're smiling jack i don't know why no
i think that that's a good point it
could be that yeah
why are you smiling it could just be the
time of the season or something like
that and now you're connecting to
things i mean you know what i've never
had a problem with uh ordering coffee
from bankrollcoffee.com you know what
that's that's a really good point it's
so easy to go to bankrollcoffee.com and
pick out your order you could buy the
total portfolio where you get all the
coffees and one uh great nifty price and
free shipping uh
above thirty dollars
i love handing you segways anyway i
don't know that was unplanned
yeah my wife my wife likes it out here
because she has like wavy hair
so in la
the humidity like her hair is always out
of control yeah and over here she's like
oh it's so manageable
which is crazy
yeah see all the things you're learning
yeah little this is like little like
little things yeah but i didn't realize
i don't know if it's due to construction
but there are a ton of crickets out here
you guys know there are lots of crickets
here yeah they're everywhere yeah
there's a ton of them inside too and yes
yeah they're large yeah yeah i feel
almost bad walking outside because
sometimes i'll open the front door i'll
step outside and like 50 crickets are
just everywhere and i know i'm stepping
on one and i hate i hate that yeah yeah
but i don't yeah i don't know if uh
cause someone also told me because
there's construction so the ground's
vibrating so they don't know where to go
so i don't know if that's it or if it's
just vegas does indeed have it that's
gonna be crickets yeah that could be it
well i like vegas so far
um
overall though it seems like everything
you've done has been successful you've
done well at it has there any been
something that you fail that
um i think there's many failures along
the way like whether a show
concept or a new like format that we try
that doesn't do well
or like an apparel launch that didn't go
the way that we planned
but i think
with a team that knows how to like
troubleshoot and like critically think
um any time that something doesn't go
the way we want we're able to
figure out what went wrong and fix it so
everything like generally if you zoom
out it's kind of like a
like a uh what's the word like uphill
trend right yeah and what's your
schedule look like today
how busy are you day to day so now um
it's actually not that busy but during
the times that i give myself the work
time it's like i try to be as like uh
like as present as as intense as
possible so i'll wake up around six get
my kid ready take them to school drop
them off and then so pretty much from
seven till
three is our work time
and so within that time i focus on our
fitness brand which has anything to do
from apparel supplements we still have a
physical gym in la that we've got to
check up on
and i produce our just kidding news show
so i have to run all the logistics for
that
and
any other like outstanding projects
and i do that from seven till three
after three pick up our kid and then we
take them to his jiu jitsu classes
um and then after that it's just like
family time so we'll go to the park over
here or the park outside and i try to
like that that's kind of been the goal
like where me and my wife are talking
about what's the dream life and it's
let's get all our work done when the
kids at school so can have as much
family time as possible after so really
your entire day is just from seven to
three really yeah that's really what it
is that's how many hours eight hours a
day that's awesome what about weekends
the full day we just try to make it
family or visit family or do fun stuff
wow what do you think makes you so
family
oriented um i think
since i was my parents were divorced
when i was six that was something i
never had so that's something i just
valued so much
and my wife's mexican and so like
family is like one of their like
pillars of like of of like the mexican
culture where
like you always got to hang out be
together stay connected all the time i
think those two put together that was
something that was important to both of
us got it
geez what questions do you have for us
how about that how do you guys like
vegas i love it
i didn't like it at first but now i do
and are you from l.a or yeah i'm from
just like an hour north of la okay yeah
but at first i definitely i was not
having a lot of fun especially before
alex was here because
because i didn't really have any friends
at the time and i was also i was like
working a lot but then finally when alex
came here i i gave him a good amount of
work and i got i got to hang out with
him and stuff so i had a friend there uh
so that was really good and then i also
made a couple other friends at the gym
oh sick the ones over here yeah yeah i
never see you there man i did in the
beginning when i saw graham because we
didn't get our home gym uh built out yet
but then now that i have it built out we
don't really go to that gym yeah the
weights don't go up very high there
you know what i would love to go to the
home gym why don't we turn this into a
vlog
can you can you train all of us for one
episode yeah that'd be cool really alex
are you game
dude yeah but i don't want him to go
easy on me
oh you don't want to go easy no yeah
don't go easy can you go so hard on us
yeah um i could try something where you
guys will have a hard time walking yes
yes yes let's do it do you know what the
the murph is
um that's like a crossfit workout right
that yeah i could not i could barely
walk the next day and that's how i want
to feel okay yeah i don't want to feel
like that but i'll do it do you know
what a squat is
i couldn't walk the next day either yeah
yeah that would be that would be so cool
that would be super fun that's a good
plug for the sta family vlog channel
we'll link to it down below in the
description we'll do one episode where
all three of us go in and you just give
us a beating
like you just put us through the ringer
you're down the street we could walk
over there
and we won't be able to walk back is
family a big part of your like youtube
because i just heard family vlog channel
too uh well i met family vloggers in
like all of us
we call it this the family but it's uh
jack myself alex macy ramsay and the
puppy bailey oh cool so it's all of us
it's like the sta family yeah that's
awesome we have like a work family going
on yeah yeah yeah that's great yeah do
you uh did you know graham before vegas
or like where you guys were yeah yeah
i've been working with graham for maybe
like two and a half years now and uh i i
was just a fan i reached out and then
started working together and uh then i
moved in with him in la and then we both
moved here to vegas together yeah that's
cool yeah one of these days we gotta go
for jack's emails i'm only gonna give
the deal one of these days he sent me
like eight emails and just following up
and i just didn't respond to any of them
awesome and it was just like the first
email was like an intro the second email
was like hey maybe you didn't see this
email i'm bumping it upside 30 emails
like hey i'm just showing you i'm still
here and he kept doing that for months
and then email like seven or eight came
around and i remembered i was in the car
uh driving home and i was just
overwhelmed with facebook emails and so
and jack said i'm willing to do anything
just let me know what it is i don't want
money or any just just tell me what to
do and he put his phone number so i'm
like okay you know what let me see if
he's really down for anything he's gonna
go and copy these facebook emails and
it's like eight to ten hours of just
like the most menial boring work of just
sitting here copy paste copy for like
eight hours and i told jack hey if you
want to do this you don't have to do it
feel free to do it if you want to do
something and he did it like that night
the whole thing and so the next day i
was like wow this is pretty good so i
just wanted to thank him by like just
taking him out to a dinner and just
chatting and uh we had a good dinner and
i was trying to figure out like how
could i implement jack and i was like no
my emails are pretty busy so he starts
going through my emails just forwarding
over the most important stuff and then
we had the idea to do i think maybe i
had just started this the second channel
yeah the gram stefan show yeah and so i
told jack hey i'm just throwing up some
like extra content on here i want to do
phone calls like dave ramsey does
can you just go through and pick the
emails that you think are the most
interesting and then i'll just go and
talk to him for the channel
deck did that he went through hundreds
of emails were like these are the three
best people they're coordinated for 9am
9 30 and 10. just call these numbers at
these times record it
uh and then you're good and i taught
jack how to edit the video he started
editing and then um within and then now
uh jack was uh you know telling alex now
how to edit and stuff like that so but
yeah then a year later alex uh sorry a
year later jack moved into the guest
house
and uh we went full time on it and
that's uh yeah
led to this i really respect that
because like i think for a like a lot of
the
like some of the questions that i get
they always ask like how do i how do i
like pursue what i want and a lot of
people they start at one you know like i
call i call for this job or i submit
this resume
and
they don't hear back and then that's it
and i don't really think you can get
anywhere in life like that like if you
really want something you have to
send eight emails like our ceo for our
fitness brand barbara brigade
very similar story
um and now like he he's about to be like
a partner of the brand just because he's
been around for so long um but so he's
been around for uh with us for eight
years now but when we first opened our
first physical gym he
would send emails all the time and i
would see this email from my erin and
i'm like
this guy's writing like the most lengthy
emails like i don't know what the hell
i'm doing we're just opening this gym
i'm like so i would just skip them over
and over and i would just see one come
in every single week can you have this
idea for the gym that i think we could
be doing or whatever or i think we could
do this for the brand i'm all right
whatever and then uh one day i came out
of the gym this is our first location
there's only like 1700 square feet and i
see this guy just sitting in the front
like after he trained and then he was
like hey i'm aaron i'm not cool and i
didn't really put two and two together
and then he was like i'm the one who's
been writing you
uh like the emails i'm like oh [ __ ] okay
cool like nice to meet you and he was
like hey i really want to just set up a
meeting with you because i have some
plans that i want to go over through my
mind uh that i would love to like
present to you and i actually wrote like
this 10-page like business plan of how i
think the gym should be operating i'm
like what so i'm going to set up a
meeting he brings like a pretty much a
presentation of like
certain protocols that he thinks we
should be doing certain things that he
feels like we're vulnerable legally like
all kinds of stuff that i was just like
damn i need someone
with this kind of mind on my team
and we couldn't really afford him at the
time because you know like me and my
wife's goal at the time was just to have
a break even gym yep so for him to leave
his job or like we can't afford you so
we worked on like kind of like a tiered
like pay scale where he would just work
on our stuff part-time
and this was this started off in like
2013
and then he kept going and going he was
able to quit his job and then now he's
like literally like my right hand man in
the business and it started with him
writing these super long emails like
every single why didn't you get back to
him in the beginning there's too many
emails well it's like
there's ones that are like serious ones
and then there's ones that like you open
an email like the title says like hey
i'm like your biggest fan you click it
and it goes [ __ ] you i'm like oh no okay
cool so you know you kind of get jaded
reading different emails too so some of
them you just don't know what's real
what's right and then so like to kind of
like cut through the noise you do need
you know like persistence you got to
show it got it yeah and then also
then when when you meet them in person
or when you finally like are able to
have the opportunity to meet face to
face
like you already know what kind of
person they are like they're yeah
they're willing to get after it you know
so i'm like if you're willing to get
after this
then when it comes to startups or any
other type of business
like you need to be really about what
you're trying to chase and so i know
that you can apply that to this because
in business if you're working for
yourself like you can't really take no
for an answer for anything you know yeah
yeah it's very similar it reminds me of
uh alex your uh
your youtube video so dude you just like
embarrassing all right oh yeah never
mind i thought you said
i thought you were gonna say that the
thing i brought
oh well we'll talk about that too thanks
for reminding me i wasn't gonna bring
that up but uh now we will uh so jack
and i wanted to to have a third person
come on the team so our idea originally
it did not go over well uh was to uh ask
people to make a youtube video
telling uh explaining to us why they
should come work with us
and in the video we wanted to make a
point that like hey it's not going to be
glamorous work and you're going to be
expected to do
anything i mean not like illegally of
course but like jack's example was that
you would be willing to do jack's
laundry okay and people did not like
that they did they got upset they got
really really
hate comments with lots of likes on the
comments yeah i can't believe they would
be paying someone to sit dude jack's
launch they're like what is jackie king
does he think he's like a pharaoh i
thought it was demeaning work wow yeah
and it's just weird because
it made sense we like we posted this
thing unlisted you know we we made it
public or whatever and we thought to
ourselves this is totally normal we
didn't think anything of it like asking
someone to be your assistant and do
laundry like
like we didn't think we thought we could
pick up bailey's poop and pick up
bailey's we literally thought to
ourselves like oh yeah yeah that's fine
because we would do that i would i would
do it if it's something that you want
you'll put anything on the line yeah you
will do whatever it is like i don't know
so we didn't think anything of it some
people did obviously they're the ones
that didn't get the job yeah
and you're alex's look at me now guys
but he hasn't done my laundry yeah whoa
that's crazy we never really seriously
expected someone to do that it was more
expensive to say like someone that would
do something like that someone that
would do anything it was more so too but
that's literally what an assistant is
like
to save your time yeah you can i mean
there's all kinds of sisters personal
assistants there's executive assistants
there's people that go that like i think
like uh diddy for example i think he has
just a like a wardrobe assistant because
he needs to travel with 12 suitcases wow
so he can't have his like brain
like focus on where his clothes and
shoes are because he's gonna travel with
like hundreds of pairs of shoes so he
has like an assistant
just to here's your necklace sir or here
you know like there's like and i'm sure
that person's doing the laundry yeah and
there's people that have like the this
is my my vehicle's assistant because
everywhere i travel i'm gonna bring like
30 cars with me yeah you got to find a
way to keep them washed clean drive them
whatever so like
i don't know i think uh
maybe
people project their own
insecurity on it or
i don't know to me like when you're
hiring someone as long as it's legal
there's
everything else it's up to the two
people that make the agreement we
weren't forcing anyone to do anything
yeah cause it's almost like hey uh my
neck hurts
can i pay you like 50 bucks and you just
massage me for 10 minutes some people
might think that's demeaning
on someone else you know but it's like
well if it's between these two people
and it's legal like any type of
agreement should be fine i don't know
my neck kind of irritating
and i also think coming from like a
startup entrepreneurial
environment that's just something you're
used to you know like when we first had
our jk studio we were cleaning the
bathrooms yeah like we take like when we
have guests come and they
take a dump and if it's not nice we
gotta clean it we empty out the garbage
so i think like when you own a business
you're so used to
doing everything from a to z even the
stuff that people think it's what is the
word that they use like the meaning the
meaning like even the quote unquote
demeaning thing
um but i think it's because
you've done it where you're like
it wasn't demeaning to me because i did
it and i knew it was a necessary thing
so i'm just like okay cool so now
uh anyone else want to do this so i can
continue to grow the business yeah but
yeah i guess like for people they have
to
it's an ego thing it could be it could
be yeah yeah and also people
look it's easy for people to know their
own worth right yeah but it's difficult
for a business to know their worth they
kind of have to prove themselves before
the business starts to understand okay
this is you know the value that you can
provide yeah so they probably think that
they
i don't know are worth a lot more
but anyway we got alex
and alex had such a great youtube video
it was just it was very thoughtful
that's what i liked it was very
thoughtful well planned out
um
a few like little inside things with
coffee it's just very creative and then
and that's what really stood out and
then when he showed up here's the party
didn't he a little embarrassed about
this uh he shows up with a like a like a
presentation
of all the things that we should be
doing or that he wants to take on and
he's like the iced coffee hour he needs
a clips channel so i want to do these
clips and i want to post them here and i
want to do you know and he had a whole
outline of what he wanted to do we're
like yep they're all pretty good ideas i
think there's maybe one that we hadn't
done i don't know why we hadn't i know
alex you should go over that
yeah we should well one of the things on
there was getting this uh live switcher
yep which is implemented now you know so
you're editing like on the fly yeah yeah
that's awesome right now yeah so what
alex does is uh we'll go through the
video and just do a few fine clips and
maybe it's parts where it uh we've
talked a little bit too long he'll clip
it down a little bit and just make it
more concise so we'll take probably a
video that's uh an hour and a half let's
just say we'll take it down to about an
hour 10. usually there's about 20
minutes in there like just cut it out
yeah that's awesome i i think i hear
like the same recurring theme like
where when you want something you're
persistent and then you over deliver
like with you i'll do this i'll do this
and then you give him like just a small
task of copying emails and you crushed
it he crushed it my ceo crushed it so i
think like that's the type of attitude
that
you need to be successful it just sucks
that that's like not really what i think
is taught in school yeah because i think
what's taught is like the kind of like
that wage mentality where if you if i do
exactly this then you pay me this but
then the problem is it's hard to grow
from that mindset because oh you only
scratch my back once i'm only going to
scratch your back once right but then if
you're like but with the other mindset
i'll scratch your back as much as you
want and you're like oh this guy's
really cool here i have these three
other projects that i think you should
jump on yeah yeah that's what i'm trying
to do now with alex he's going to edit
my first ever i've never done this
before
uh he's going to edit a video on my main
channel
i'm going to give him that are you going
to like
be like are you going to be like super
stringent on the back end or like i'm
gonna watch this over and over and over
again i don't know i'm not
i'm not i want to leave the final edit
or you're just gonna let it go no no oh
my gosh no no no i wouldn't do that no i
told alex i'm gonna film a whole video
by noon so he has between 12 p.m of
tomorrow
and uh until thursday night to get this
video to me and then we're going to go
through and add in the final touches so
by thursday night it it's done so he has
36 hours
to just i'm gonna leave it up to him how
long does it take you usually i could
pro i could probably edit this video
it's going to be b-roll intensive i
could probably do it in five hours maybe
six
six at the most so you feel like you're
giving it more than enough time
yes i do okay yeah that's pretty cool i
would say for me it's five hours for
alex i'd say it's probably 10.
just because he's gonna learn the ropes
but uh are you up to the challenge alex
or do you feel like you're gonna mess it
up no i'm up for the challenge or do you
think you're gonna smash anything that
graham can even think like you're
knocking out of the park i mean i'm sure
there's going to be a couple things that
graham's going to want me to change up
you know for his liking for sure and um
you know i've only been editing full
time for six months but
um i think it'll be good i think it's
going to be really good yeah jack edits
right now the uh family vlog channel and
those edits are incredible but to
incorporate yeah to incorporate this
style said jack sorry alex oh okay yeah
uh so yeah so alex has been editing the
uh the vlog channel now full time and
the edits are incredible but to
incorporate his style a little bit with
mine so that it doesn't look like
i didn't edit the video i mean that
would be the goal is that it looks the
exact same yeah the same feel of it same
feel
so jack was able to learn that on the
second channel like uh in the very
beginning actually i i almost couldn't
tell which videos i edited and which one
jack edits the only ways i could tell is
because he doesn't zoom the way like i
would zoom like sometimes like i always
zoom in zoom in zoom in when i end a
thought it's like the total zoom and
then when i start a new thought it's
back yeah sometimes jack you you'll zoom
in and then mid thought it'll be all i
know i knew that you did that yeah i
figured that out it's like it's pretty
smart it's like you further on the the
opinion you further
pull it back but even now but even now
sometimes i've noticed i've been like
mid-thought and it goes back oh yeah
that's just because i need it i change
it uh i think a little quicker okay yeah
anyway so that's that's the only way i
can tell the jacket it's this video who
do you think is stronger between graham
and i
hmm
upper body maybe graham i don't know he
looks pretty like yeah well i'm wearing
a baggy shirt okay
did you guys play sports i i don't like
that i i ran cross-country i did not
play any sports i assume your legs are
pretty strong i don't know or at least
have really good endurance uh yeah i did
i mean i i mean i still do like i can go
out and do a five mile run nothing
well i mean i definitely say it's like
something yeah like i would be i'll be a
little tired after a five mile run but
yeah not as tired as the average person
definitely i see you know jack just so
you guys know i did pull that exact
question
on the sta family link down below
community tab i said who is the
strongest a family member
all right i can't know that
overwhelmingly
jack won at thirty percent no yes come
on followed by ramsay
27
followed by graham at 18 oh that's
that's false come on he's he's you're
switching
jack and graham
who's ramsay ramsay's the cat yeah
so the cat's stronger than graham but
people they're taking it as a joke like
they're joking when they when they
select you it's it's not meant to be
serious they're just messing around
really
is that so
that's true i don't think so that's the
truth it was meant as a joke they
want to make you feel baby your arms are
very large yes how often do you guys go
to the gym over here uh i try to go
i i try to go
four days a week lately it's pretty good
yeah
yeah four five five days a week and uh i
used to do six but now i'm down to four
or five do you guys go together no
we will you do
because your schedules are different
kind of yeah jack light's going in the
morning you guys that live in the same
house yes yeah i live right there but
your schedules are just i also like
going honestly kind of like going alone
oh
i push myself a lot harder when i when i
work out alone i don't know what i'm
doing i go in there and i lift lots of
weight yeah yeah and i make sure i'm
tired and then i leave that's good yeah
our schedules are different uh every
time listen almost every single time i
go to the gym i text jack hey you want
to come with me no i'm editing or it's
usually i just win so jack goes in the
morning but if i go in the morning it
throws me off for the entire day like i
gotta get right to work
if i don't get right to work i lose out
on the most creative work
which is for me is in the morning yeah a
lot of people like that
it's interesting though because graham
will start working out and he will show
it like he already will look way buffer
if he goes to the gym like three times
however i don't look buff and i've
buffer and i've been going to the gym
for probably six months now
is there any explanation to that
i don't know i might have to see you
guys shirtless and then see what you
guys look like like when you guys train
and then three months later all right
you know what that'll be in the family
vlog channel how's that you're gonna get
the full breakdown everything in this to
family vlog channel you know it'll be
funny if you give us like a workout
routine or something like this yeah and
we do a follow-up six months later and
we see the progress yeah now in six
months from now i'll give you guys a
word routine and we'll see what happens
in like 30 days
oh
all right the 30-day makeover six months
six months it's hard to stick to
sometimes i'll push myself yeah there's
things that pop up all the time people
travel
all right 30 days is doable deal let's
do it
cool i think we're good
so this has been so productive
thank you so much thank you so much for
having me it really is amazing to meet
you and have you on oh awesome this is
so much fun so i really appreciate it
guys thank you so much for watching
we'll link to all of your information
down below in the description make sure
to subscribe
don't forget to do that you want to tell
them to smash the like button yeah smash
the like button and uh
see you guys next time all right i'll
see you guys bye
oh now we stand up oh yeah
there we go
oh sure i was wearing shorts